make sure that you know what you want
and go for it I'm totally like a
confident person I'll stand up to
everybody
I just love to express myself I always
just focus on the positive side
what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from the Canadian
singer-songwriter Avril Lavigne and my
take on her top ten rules for success
rule number nine is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best
if you could go back like in a time
machine and speak to you when you were
15 you know what what sort of advice
would you give yourself knowing what you
know now pretty much the same advice
that I do know which is make sure that
you know what you want and go for it
and don't let anyone change your mind um
I was always very focused and I've
always been the type of person that
listens to my my gut and I think it's
important to do that to go with your to
go with your instincts and I would say
that to myself
and I definitely did do that pretty much
everyone that's working with me gets
like what I wear I'm into what I like
and stuff what there ever is a situation
that I'm totally like a confident person
I'll stand up to everybody and tell them
like no I really believe this this is
what my guts telling me out and and yeah
I'm not if there's something that's
bugging me like I'll totally speak up to
it I think speak up about it and not shy
and I'm not gonna let it's too risky to
let you know this is my life I don't
want to like mess up my career and so I
need to speak up and like tell people
what I think under my skin I kind of
just went right off of my tour into
writing the record and it was durman in
six months I knew how I wanted it to
sound and how I wanted it to come across
and so I had to share my vision
I gotta judge everybody let yourself
I feel like this record is more
emotional for me you know it just it's
deeper and I just feel like I was able
to express myself on a different level
I've always been a really carefree
spirit I've always wanted to just have
fun and so I feel like I just love to
express myself and to be emotional and
and I feel like on camera and stuff like
that I feel like that that's what I do
and I was born with
let's do this I guess the only thing is
when I was younger you know having to
deal with why don't people like me you
know I didn't do anything to them that
would have been the struggle I guess if
anything but that is just how it is and
there's something you do about it
so I always just focus on the positive
side and that and the positive side is a
very large side I'm really focused I'm
here I'm in Hollywood because I have a
job I'm a songwriter I'm a singer and
performer I spend the majority of my
time on the road touring and you know is
something that was my dream I worked
really hard for it so you know I'm just
I'm really dedicated to my career and
also expanding and to other things like
a bead on
now I have like great opportunities I'm
in a really great situation I'm very
thankful and I want to do other things
too you know I'm looking for a lead role
in a movie and that'll be you know
that'll be a challenge which is what I
like and I want to do other thing is
clothing
that's like very me like my style and
like to other things and create like as
I want to do million things I think like
for me I'm I'm a young free spirit and
like I work hard but I also like to not
take things too seriously and really
like coming back to the song it's just
about like you know doesn't matter what
age you are and you know it's all about
it's your state of mind so I think you
know a lot of times it's it's it's an
it's an approach it's one thing and yeah
I think it's positive
I always tweet my fans and ask them hey
like what song do you like I'm record
and how do you felt feel about these two
songs being single I like I get to read
their feedback and be connected with the
fans through Twitter and it's really
cool cuz I could have that personal
relationship and we can kind of
communicate that way and so it's nice
for me I just think it's really
important to listen to yourself and to
be yourself and believe in yourself and
whatever it is that anything that you're
trying to do absolutely that applies to
life generally got to be happy like
sorry I have to make music for myself I
have to go with in the direction that
I'm feeling them that I want because I
you know I can't do something that I
don't want to do and then not be happy
it's all about being happy that's always
been my enough message to my fans it's
just be who you are know who you are and
go after it
when you
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Luca on my team
who's in the comments a lot and does
some of the research of the videos asked
me to she's his favorite singer so this
one's for you Luca if there's someone
you'd like to vote on for the next top
10 check out the link in the description
and go and have your say filing what
they give a quick shredded to chemo to
da ho thank you so much for picking up a
cup of my book your one word and taking
that amazing picture with the book at
the eiffel tower I should have done that
when I went to Paris anyway thank you so
much for your support I really
appreciate it and I'm so glad you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon
well I think because I was so popular
when I came out there was a lot of
people who were like oh she's fake and
she's not real and and that to me was
weird because I felt like I am the one
who's real if anyone would have told me
how to be they would have said dress
nicer talk better like don't swear like
the you know what I mean they would have
turned me into someone nicer like I
don't know a Hilary Duff or something
yeah I think she I'm not just seeing her
in any way but someone more like that I
think and and I was just very myself and
different from everyone and so to hear
people say that I was fake I was like no
no I'm like the most real thing ever
unlike myself I've heard in many ways on
menu album goodbye lullaby I wrote half
of the record by myself and I produced
two songs and played more instruments on
it and where they typically usually just
say co-write on my music this time I
pushed myself I produced and and this is
also my fourth world tour so I feel that
with every album every tour I'm
constantly learning more through my
experiences
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]